Owen a deputy division chief of the
monetary and capital markets Department
before taking your questions we will
kick let me kick start our conversation
today and turn to Tobias and ask him a
few questions Tobias a lot has happened
since we last spoke in October including
the recent turmoil in the banking sector
how do you assess the Global Financial
stability and in light of the recent
events yeah thanks so much uh it's my
pleasure to be here
um so we have seen a turmoil in the
banking sector in the US and in
Switzerland and that really reflects uh
the heightened vulnerabilities that have
been building up over years of low
interest rates as interest rates are
being raised vulnerabilities are
appearing we saw that already last
October when we met here for the annual
meetings where we saw stress in the
non-bank financial sector in the UK more
specifically at that time and we have
seen it in March in the banking sector
in the US in Switzerland there are
certainly other vulnerabilities out
there and sharp adjustments in interest
rates sharp adjustments in expectations
can trigger further stresses I think one
of the key lessons from both the March
episode and the October episode is that
while their vulnerabilities that can be
triggered and can test Financial
stability there are also policy tools
that are available to policy makers in
central banks and in Deposit Insurance
agencies as well as Finance Ministries
and what we have seen is that these
policy tools have been deployed in a
very effective manner so that any threat
to financial stability was
contained and debated very quickly
so vulnerabilities are there but there
are also many tools to contain risks to
financial stability
how can policy makers fight both
inflation and contain Financial
stability risks yeah I think what has
happened in the past month uh is very
telling in that respect uh central banks
will always try uh to use tools
separately uh to fight inflation via
monetary policy and uh to ensure
Financial stability via other tools
um so
starting with the financial stability
angle for example in the U.S case
a systemic risk exemption was being used
by the FDIC to make sure that the runoff
deposits would not spread to other banks
that was very effective and uh you know
any turmoil in the banking sector in the
US was mitigated by the deployment of
that tool there was also new lending
facility that was deployed by the
Federal Reserve in order to allow more
effective lending to those banks that
were under stress in the case of
Switzerland the government supported a
merger between two Banks which again
stabilized the financial stability
situation and finally in the case of the
UK back in October the bank of England
deployed targeted and time limited asset
purchases to stabilize the ldis that
were in under stress and so in all of
these cases basically central banks
could continue to tighten monetary
policy because they had the tools to
contain threats to financial stability
the Federal Reserve increased interest
rates after the svb episode The Swiss
National Bank increased interest rates
after the Credit Suisse merger and of
course back in since October the bank of
England has hacked interest rates since
the ldi episode so this is really uh The
Playbook uh you know that is that is
ideal where their financial stability
problems use targeted tools to address
those and continue to use your monetary
policy to find inflation inflation
remains High well above Target in many
countries
um what is priced at the markets at the
moment is a relatively optimistic view
about inflation going forward uh
inflation is expected it's priced in by
markets to come back down to targets
fairly quickly and while we certainly
hope that this is going to be the case
there's certainly risks around this uh
outlook on inflation inflation could
prove to be more persistent which could
lead to a reassessment of the path of
policy for uh monetary policy and uh you
know that could again trigger certain
financial sector instabilities so
vulnerabilities are certainly created
both in the banks and in the non-bank
financial sector I think
now we turn to your questions for those
watching online you can submit your
questions via the online media briefing
Center or WebEx for the WebEx we kindly
ask you to please raise your hand and uh
we are your hand feature we're going to
take questions from the room raise your
hand and please identify yourself and
your organization
called this
okay thank you Colby Smith with the
financial times uh the report closely
links the recent banking turmoil uh with
the rapid pace of monetary tightening
that we we've seen in the past year
um were central banks like the fed and
the ECB wrong to front load uh their
interest rate increases
um and and Implement these jumbo rate
Rises and uh how concerned are you that
what is ultimately required to quell
inflation uh is going to uh spark some
of those risks that reflect in the
report in terms of financial stability
yeah that's an excellent question and um
um you know I think there's a question
about front loading uh certainly I mean
we have seen some countries starting
even earlier than say the us or the
other or the European Central Bank in
terms of tightening monetary policy many
Emerging Markets actually preceded the
advanced economies in terms of
tightening monetary policy I think the
pace of of tightening uh is uh it has
been has been appropriate uh and uh we
continue to expect that inflation is
going to converge back to Target
um and uh you know what we have seen is
that uh central banks and deposit
insurance companies do have the tools uh
to address any uh turbulence in the
banking sector so I will not expect at
this point that uh you know monetary
policy uh will be uh any any different
uh because of financial stability uh
concerns
um now having said that of course there
is an impulse from the change in the
market assessment of the cost of capital
to the banks
so you know stock prices of banks have
dropped in both the US and your area and
that is expected to have an impact on
lending so we provide some estimates of
that channel in the Global Financial
stability report and we have seen you
know some degree of contraction in
lending in some countries so you know
there's only some degree of financial
tightening but that is not in and of
itself a financial stability issue this
is more a question about monetary policy
transmission
um and finally I would say that um of
course the svb episode was uh related to
uh you know changes and expectations
about the future rate path there were
upset surprises to inflation earlier in
the year and that was certainly one of
the trigger for
um you know a pressure on svb but svb
really was an outlier relative to other
banks in terms of unrealized losses and
the share of deposits the share of
wholesale deposits and so it was much
more vulnerable than say your average
you know Regional Bank or average Bank
in in general so at this point I don't
saying that a monetary policy will be
any different due to financial stability
concerns
thank you
Alex Brunner the daily mail
um do you think that um it was wise for
central banks to I mean you seem to
praise central banks for raising
interest rates after the banking crisis
but um doesn't classical economic theory
tell us that this is not the right
moment to type manager conditions by
raising interest rates that perhaps they
should have taken the pause and seeing
how credit conditions went before moving
ahead and that may cause problems server
down down the road yeah and secondly um
you referred in rather friendly terms to
some of these bank bailouts don't they
run in don't they fly in the face of the
kind of rules which were set by
Financial stability board after the
great financial crisis yeah let me start
with the second question and then move
uh to the first question so uh you know
the second question uh is is really
about uh the kind of tools uh that are
available for central banks under
extreme stress
um and so resolution is certainly one
thing uh that the policy Community
around the world has been working on
since the 2008 crisis
um you know a lot of effort has been put
into a building a resolution regimes now
in the case of uh uh you know a Credit
Suisse that resolution regime was not
being used but I would argue that the
outcome was fairly similar to what would
have occurred on the resolution of
course it's always difficult uh to you
know judge in red respect those outcomes
but I do think the bottom line for
financial stability is that it it
contained uh you know the the uh any
further fallouts um uh from the
pressures uh in this uh in this
particular situation uh in terms of the
U.S uh Banks uh the systemic risk
assumption was being used and that does
have a cost uh to the uh Deposit
Insurance Fund
um but of course the systemic risk
assumption was created for these types
of circumstances so I think it was again
successful in terms of containing uh uh
you know any spread of of loss of trust
or withdrawal of deposits now you're
asking about sort of like the costs and
benefits and absolutely
um you know going forward I think there
will be a debate about whether policy
instruments institutions can be designed
to mitigate moral hazard even more right
um you know unfortunately uh it is it is
very difficult to entirely get rid of
moral hazard but you can minimize it as
much as possible I think the Traders
were reasonable in these uh situations
they were you know fairly contained but
of course to contain moral hazard even
further is is certainly a desirable uh
policy outcome while containing
Financial stability threats so there's a
debate about you know what do you do in
times of Crisis versus what you do in
normal times in terms of Regulation
policy tools Etc and certainly there
will be a debate about you know
regulations and containing uh
risk-taking in terms of your first
question which was really about sort of
like you know to what extent uh would
financial sector developments be taken
into account in monetary policy so I
would distinguish two different things
so one is that of course Titan monetary
policy always works through the
financial sector to an important degree
it's not the only transmission Channel
but it's an important transmission
channel so as monetary policy is
tightened lending standards are going to
be tightened and you know credit Supply
is going to be constrained at some point
That's a classic so like transmission
Channel and that is certainly taken into
account in terms of setting monetary
policy I.E to what extent is your
tightening leading to the desired
outcome of Titan and credit supply of
course there's a different question
which is if such tightening is so like
this orderly disruptive and and uh you
know triggers sort of like financial
crisis and again to date I think uh
central banks have had the tools to
contain those crises so that they will
certainly take the orderly tightening of
credit conditions into account but they
have not had to take you know financial
crisis saying to account in monetary
policy and that is what central banks
are aiming to do as much as possible
uh yes I think I think to the extent
that they can separate the two uh that
is certainly desirable of course there
is a point where it becomes very
difficult to separate the tool we're
discussing that in the Global Financial
stability report uh so you know if you
really get to a point where you know uh
financial sector turbulence is of macro
criticality you know at that point uh it
is it is more difficult to separate uh
but you know so far
um you know there's certainly you know
monetary policy transmission through
bank lending will feed into monetary
policy but the turmoil in and of itself
is probably not yet at the level of of
microcriticality and hopefully will not
get there
at the back
this side
Jeremy won a Daily Telegraph
um in in the Rio there is a
characterization of the present a spike
in interest rates as a kind of brief
aberration with rates returning to their
pre-pandemic level uh sometime in the uh
sometime soon in fact the natural rate
of interest for the UK is actually
forecast to be lower than it was before
the the pandemic
um given uh the effects of these very
low interest rates on financial
stability asset prices and so on is this
and whether this is that this view is
right or wrong is this an entirely
desirable State of Affairs to see uh uh
essentially the return of free money
yeah that's a that's an excellent
question and it's really at the core of
monetary policy is this neutral level of
interest rate so this is what is
referred to as our star
um and what the real chapter is doing is
to provide estimates uh for for the
whole world and for different countries
in terms of where these neutral interest
rates are going to go uh there's some
debate among economists on whether we're
going to return to those relatively low
levels of real interest rates that we
saw in the post-crisis era and uh you
know our research certainly uh argues uh
uh affirmatively so we do believe that
we will return back to relatively low
interest rates how long it's going to
take you know there's a lot of
uncertainty around that and what the
exact level is of course there's also
some uncertainty I would add to that you
know what is done in the Rio chapter is
really a kind of
um you know fundamental economic
approach so using modeling and filtering
techniques you can also look at Market
implied kind of metrics of Our Stars so
these are sort of like you know far in
the future forward rates adjusted for
risk premium liquidity premium and those
actually line up fairly well with those
more economic theory based approaches so
the market assessment of our style is
actually also pointing uh towards
relatively low neutral rate find the
future now how we are going to get there
how fast we're going to get there I
think there's quite a bit of question
now you're asking about the desirability
of of allow our star and you know it's
really not a policy choice I would argue
right so
um you know while the level of interest
rates is a choice by the Central Bank
the neutral level of interest rates is
given by deeper economic fundamentals
such as productivity growth you know lay
labor and you know certain uh
Technologies in the financial sector so
the financial intimidation technology is
going to play a role but it is not so
like part of a day-to-day monetary
policy so
um you know in terms of asset
evaluations uh you know absolutely when
interest rates are low valuations uh you
know tend to uh to tend to be elevated
uh but it's not so like um necessarily a
variable of choice for the policy maker
side of the room the lady in the pink
jacket please
also CNBC in figure 1.4 funding stress
surgeon European bond market amid
Central Bank liquidity contraction Italy
stands out as the only country with
outstanding tltros as a share of
national GDP higher than that of excess
liquidity I was wondering if you can
elaborate on this and explain the
potential implications for the country
um let me try to to Fabio to go into
more detail and then I will compliment
so I think they were trying to focus on
some possible stress Channel coming from
the banking sector uh turmoil here in
the U.S and so one of these segment has
been a lot of improvements since then we
have seen across risk assets but one
segment will continue to see stress it's
funding for banks so we look through the
channel for the U.S side for example
like the regional banks in particular
the increase they need to increase
deposit and then we try to do the same
exercise uh for Europe right so we have
seen some for example professional swap
spread in expectation for Scouts
collateral
um and so then we try to think about
what are other possible reasons they are
more unique to the URL and one of them
was the fragmentation rates that had
been highlighted by the ECB itself with
the creation of new TPI instrument what
we're trying to do there is with the
upcoming uh deadline for repayment of
the ltros trying to figure out what kind
of whether there is a risk of funding
pressure and so we compare the extent of
outstanding TLT errors with the excess
liquidity available
and they trying to uh flag or one of
there is one possible risk monitor which
is the extent to it uh Italian Banks may
need additional funding as they get
close to alteros given how much success
liquidity they have now clearly the sdcb
is aware of this as we know we have a
tool so they can address and so to be as
well in trying to separate monetary
policy from Financial stability issue
they have a tools that they can use and
deploy should they need to address
possible fragmentation risk
yeah let me just reiterate that message
right so the transmission protection
instrument the TPI has not yet been
deployed but it is certainly uh aimed at
leaning against any uh fragmentation
pressures that were so relevant uh 10
years ago in the in the Euro um uh
crisis
um so
um you know I think the ECB has been
very clear that um uh you know inflation
is the first order objective for
monetary policy and uh that any
Financial stability risks are contained
and of course they do have a very rich
toolkit to address those financial
stability issues
and stay on this side a little
hi uh Sophie sound from 21st century
business China and my question is the
Global Financial system is highly
interconnected and the svb incident
trigger a turmoil a Global Financial
Market do you think there could be a
greater Global risk in the near future
and how is the current Global Financial
system different from that of the 2008
crisis considering its Global inference
should the fat take more into account of
the spill over effect to Emerging Market
while pursuing domestic policy goals
thank you yeah thank you so much for uh
that very important question so let me
start with Emerging Markets uh and
perhaps Charles can compliment me on the
Emerging Market side as well
um you know we have seen an incredible
Brazilians in Emerging Market the major
emerging markets in particular
um and um you know that has uh been
going on for a number of years
um so
um you know imagine markets were some of
the earliest uh uh uh countries that
increased monetary policy uh interest
rates in order to fight inflation
um when the svb turmoil hit uh you know
there was a sell-off of Bank shares in
the US and the Euro area but much less
in Emerging Markets
um and while there's certainly a a broad
heterogeneity in terms of you know the
bank systems in emerging markets in
general there is a somewhat smaller
share of duration so Securities
portfolios that are losing value when
interest rates are being raised and
there's a larger share of retail so
stickier deposits relative to the kind
of wholesale deposits that we have seen
in svb so I think that is one source of
stability
now of course again in both in advanced
economies and in Emerging Markets there
is a weak tale of Banks and you know svb
was one particular example of a bank
with high vulnerability and it's
certainly possible that you know if
address shocks hit you know banks in
other countries might also get into the
stress but this gets me to the policy
toolkit right so they are the
vulnerabilities and and then they're the
policy tools of course cattle and
liquidity today is much higher than
there were in the 2008 crisis to date
much of the asset side of banks have
been impacted by interest rate risk and
less so by credit risk right so we are
expecting that the economy globally is
going to slow down but when you look at
so like metrics of you know credit risks
on on banks those have not deteriorated
sharply in most countries now that could
change if there is uh you know a sharp
deterioration of real activity but to
date we see more of uh those uh you know
losses or either realized or unrealized
related to higher interest rates
um and um you know relative to 2008 I
think uh the the you know the first
order uh difference is that uh you had
this massive deleveraging cycle that was
triggered in the financial sector right
the housing market declined
um Banks and non-bank financial
institutions around the world were
exposed to housing and they were forced
to deliver and
um I think there are less of these the
leveraging pressures uh to date because
you don't have this common credit shock
at the moment now having said that of
course if we were to enter into a more
adverse scenario
um you know the wheel has a baseline an
adverse and a severely adverse so if we
went to the severely adverse scenario of
course uh you know Financial stability
would be uh threatened to a much higher
degree
uh do you want to elaborate on the major
markets yeah thanks for being uh just to
compliment that uh let's talk about
monetary policy you know many EMS as we
pointed out before actually acted uh
ahead of AES in in addressing the global
inflation shocks that were coming so
that has actually shielded them uh from
some of that and uh much of the FX
depreciation that we saw uh last year is
that much of that is now recovered uh
and and in many cases conditions are
roughly the same as they were uh prior
to the
um prior to the uh uh February of last
year uh also it's true that em uh banks
have seen little sell-off in their
equity and in general as to be just
mentioned they are much less exposed to
um duration risk it's more about credit
risk in Emerging Markets where you know
something we continue to monitor because
uh there's more macroeconomic volatility
and more chances of uh higher npls and
losses in Emerging Markets if there is
another uh slow down uh globally
um I would also add to that that another
area we're focused on in in EMS
particularly in the banking sector is in
Frontier markets where as we know the
Global Financial stability report uh
there's been a growing Bank Sovereign
Nexus that is to say the purchases of
local sovereign debt by local banks and
another issue that we're quite focused
on and is related to this question about
global tightening of conditions is uh
the lack of Market access for the more
vulnerable countries in international
sovereign debt markets and so uh that's
an area that we continue to uh to
monitor
uh we moved to this side of the room uh
the lady in the Yellow Jacket
thank you
um my name is
from Egypt I have two quick questions my
first one is speaking of the banking
turmoil the U.S has recently experienced
it how such a great how do you see such
a crisis affecting the emerging markets
and developing countries including a
developing country like Egypt my second
one is on inflation which is a big deal
now for the these economies and markets
so how the depreciation of local
currencies and more tightening of policy
monetary policy can contribute to curb
The Soaring inflation in such markets
thank you
so
um let me let me start uh with the with
the second part which is about inflation
and um uh you know in general
um we tend to think of monetary policy
as being the main instrument uh for
fighting inflation uh so uh tighter
monetary conditions are certainly uh the
first uh response
um and that in turn has implications uh
for uh the exchange rate
um now uh in uh many Emerging Markets
fiscal policy can also play a
complementary role to monitor policies
so
um you know uh tightening of fiscal
policy while tightening monetary policy
can together be more powerful than just
using one instrument at a time now
having said that of course in many
Emerging Markets middle income countries
um you know you know the population is a
severely impacted by the rise in food
prices and energy prices so any physical
action would have to watch out for the
most vulnerable segments of the
population so you want to you know
readjust the overall stance of fiscal
policy while
um uh you know watching out for those
that are most vulnerable in terms of
food and energy prices in particular
um now uh you know in terms of banking
development so you know we we addressed
some of those issues already
um so there really is quite a bit of
heterogeneity across emerging markets
and and middle income countries in terms
of uh how strong the banks are how many
credit losses they are how much of a
Deposit Insurance there is and what
other tools the central bank and the
finance Ministries have in order to deal
with any any distress in in weaker
segments as I said earlier any contagion
has been very limited to date but of
course uh you know there are possible
shocks that could trigger
um you know turbulence in in some
markets thank you I
uh Greg Robb from markets watch did
crypto contribute to the banking stress
by taking needed liquidity out of the
system
yeah
um so we have seen relatively uh High
correlations uh between
um you know Equity markets and crypto
valuations
um so uh in particular last year uh as
Equity Market declines uh uh crypto
evaluations declined as well and there
were certain pockets of some
institutions uh that were particularly
catering uh to the crypto universe that
saw uh you know some exposure uh to
crypto but in general
there has been uh only a limited uh
spillover from the crypto Universe to
the financial sector uh the crypto
universe is fairly uh fairly distinct at
this point uh from the broader financial
sector so there are some interlinkages
but they remain fairly small and
um you know the uh both the the rise in
valuations and the bus and valuations uh
and now of course valuations uh have
been uh increasing again
um you know those have not uh directly
uh been uh uh uh fueling evaluations in
the traditional financial sector so I
think the causality really goes from the
financial sector to crypto but to date
uh very little from the crypto sector to
the traditional financial sector with
the exception of some institutions uh
that were in distress okay go back to
the room uh the gentleman
with Today News Africa in Washington DC
I I won't take you back to Africa as you
know Bola Ahmed tinubo has just won the
Nigerian presidential election and will
be inaugurated next month which is a big
change because the previous government
was there for eight years
um
and we we know some of the problems with
that servicing subsidies and
vulnerabilities can you talk a little
bit more about how stable is Nigerian
economy some of the recommendation and
more broadly in sub-Saharan Africa the
same questions thank you yeah absolutely
so
um so
um you know we do have a regional press
briefing that will talk about specific
countries so I don't want to go
specifically into the situation in
Nigeria but I'm happy to talk about
sub-Saharan Africa more generally
um so uh you know we do have a number of
countries that are facing uh challenges
in terms of uh that uh service
um uh you know many sub-Saharan African
countries have seen their borrowing
costs rise and
um there have been attempts to
restructure
um you know the debt in in a number of
countries we're working very hard to
together with our membership to get to a
speedy data structuring I think it's
absolutely key to get countries back on
track in terms of microeconomic
stability and growth prospects we have a
sovereign debt Roundtable meeting this
week I think it's tomorrow in order to
make progress on the debt issue but of
course we also
work directly with many countries in
Africa on capacity buildings so working
directly with the central banks with the
Regulatory Agencies and the finance
Ministries to build capacity to really
build the foundation for long-lasting
growth build the foundation for good
policies that are going to build a
resilient economies
um I don't know whether no that was an
excellent summary the only thing I would
just add is that we continue to be
focused on lack of Market access for
many of these countries so we see this
very sharp bifurcation in terms of
international Sovereign Bond issuance
between investment grade Emerging
Markets where spreads have actually
stated relatively low levels despite uh
stress uh since covet has started and
for high yield issuers where many of
them uh issuance in international
markets is now quite challenging I think
at latest count is about 19 of them with
spreads of over 700 basis points where
issuance in the past has been highly
challenging and again many of these are
in sub-Saharan Africa so that's an area
that we uh continue to focus on is to be
as mentioned this is closely related to
the question of
proactive Sovereign structure for
countries in debt distress
the gentleman on the side
yeah
thank you my name is Ali I'm from
Pakistan and my question is pertaining
to this the low income and uh Emerging
Market that's at least a distress
situation I mean with so you talked
about the targeting in in the developed
world where where certain banks are
there and and as you relate with while
keeping the monetary policy tied to
control the inflation in in in in those
economies with that distresses there
that that their High concentration of
sovereign debt and that's that's being
where the challenges of the Dead East
structuring as well so and and because
of those uh the interest rate high
Global High there's a currency pressure
and then inflation and you know High
interest rate and and again that's where
in Country Life Pakistan we're very very
high sovereign
uh stressing the whole domestic
Financial system as well so is there
going to be any targeted approach on on
in economies like this where where you
have a unique problem the private credit
is being Contracting while while the uh
the the the sovereign
debt is growing because of those issues
of the high high rates and and
in excess of the financial Global
Financial markets so and again this is a
connecting to the sovereign debt
restructuring talk and and it's it's a
back to the rising uh uh you know uh
poverty with with inflation
approaching the hyper depression and the
poverty is rising in those economies so
it's it's a very important
socio-economic issues to deal with it so
how are you going to Target in in such
economies like yeah absolutely
um so this is really the bread of butter
of of our our work in in fund programs
um
um you know is to to get back to a path
of stability
um and um you know our work uh on data
structuring and banking restructuring as
well is particularly focused on
restoring
um stability uh to get back to growth
and uh to get back to inclusive growth
um you know I think we have made a lot
of progress in recent years but the
covet pandemic and then the war in
Ukraine were certainly big setbacks for
for big parts of the population and of
course
um you know you you mentioned Pakistan
um you know climate challenges are also
uh uh coming uh in in many countries
Pakistan is one example I think many
sub-Saharan African economies and other
countries around the world are already
feeling uh the heightened uh you know
pressures through climate so all of
these are issues that we're we're
tackling uh squarely I do also want to
point that in the Global Financial
stability report last year we had a
specific chapter on The Sovereign
banking Nexus and the financial
stability uh issues around that so it's
certainly something that we've looked at
in detail and um you know fixing debt
and fixing Banks that's that's the
that's the the the brief the gentleman
here please
yeah
Larry Elliott of the Guardian central
banks uh are assuming that there is no
conflict between their monetary policy
and their financial stability objectives
and you seem to be agreeing with them
um how confident are you in that
assessment or is there a risk in six
months time when we all meet again in
Marrakech that the canary and the coal
mine that you talk about in the gfsr has
made an unwelcome appearance yeah now
absolutely so I I think you were saying
um you know central banks are assuming
that there's no uh interaction uh I
would rather say
um you know they're working on uh trying
to separate those two things so
Financial stability from monetary policy
but of course as we're explaining in the
in the gfsr
um you know there are situations in
which financial crisis do become
microcritical so and in which you know
monetary policy may have to be adjusted
uh in the face of very severe crisis I
talked about the instruments crisis
management instruments that are
available but uh in in times of a
tighter monetary policy you know there
there can be more of a conflict than in
times when a monetary policy is being
eased we have a chapter 2 in the gfsr
that is specifically addressing these
kind of uh uh uh the Nexus between
monetary policy International stability
with respect to the stress in the
non-bank financial sector and
um yeah I don't know if you want to uh I
think I would like to step back for a
second and put this in perspective so
we're coming out of 10 plus years of
very slow interest rate low volatility
subdue inflation and so as when you
start raising interest rate not just the
extent to increase but the speedo
inquiry
um it is possible that there are cracks
in the system and in some sense that's
what we have been seeing uh the svb the
bank in turmoil in the US is just one
example you can go back over the last
year and think about the UK and the ldi
you can think of Korea and the project
Finance ABCD so there's a common pattern
there or some vulnerabilities that are
built over the years those include
liquid and maturity mismatch uh includes
use of financial leverage for example
some of the sap and must here so the
question is well again this is a
essentially an Albany or a more stress
to come so the counter in the coal mine
or whether it's just a natural
manifestation that you'd see after you
start hacking interest rate
and you do you need to do in a hurry
because inflation continues to be high
and and stubborn so what we try to do in
the Francis ability report is to monitor
some possible pressure point whether it
says financial institutions or the
Regionals uh Bank in the US is an
example they've been challenged on the
funding side they may be an issue in
terms of liquid interest rate risk on
the uh on the asset side uh or whether
this is other non-bank financial
institution another jurisdiction or
sectors right so sectors like the uh
Venture capitalists is one example and
technology or commercial real estate I
think we spent quite a bit of time on
the commercial real estate that's a
place where there seems to be a juncture
of different risks and different
financial institutions in the U.S
smaller Bank player role they're also a
non-bank financial institution so we're
trying to monitor effectively where
could be pressure point going forward
also being mindful though the inflation
continues to be really high and it's
important to address inflationary
pressure to avoid that false phase into
wages and and more immigration
expectations okay we'll take one more
question because we have less than a
minute please the gentleman has raised
his hand about Barry wood rthk in Hong
Kong
does increasing use of the remmb promote
Global Financial stability
um
so uh
that's uh that's a that's a very good
question so um um you know for the
moment uh the remniby has uh still uh
limited uh uh convertibility
um and uh we do expect that over time uh
convertibility will be will be increased
and that uh the remnibi is going to be
uh used uh more uh often and might be
more predominant in international
transactions
um I would distinguish uh in between uh
payments and capital markets right
um so
um you know usage for payments in and of
itself uh would not uh in general
represent uh any implications for
financial stability
uh but of course we would also explain
that Capital markets uh around renibi uh
issued Securities would develop uh over
time
um you know at the moment of course the
U.S dollar is uh the dominant currency
not just for trade but also for Capital
markets and I think on the Capital
Market side this is where the financial
stability question uh occurs and that
really goes back to the regulation
and supervision of financial
institutions that would provide the
basis for Capital markets around remnivy
so
um you know of course Chinese
authorities are committed to the
international standards for banking
supervision and for Capital markets uh
iasco a cpmi Esco principles and I think
that can really provide the foundation
of
um you know deep and liquid Capital
markets around the remnibi that is
addressing Financial stability risks
appropriately so you know it is about
the regulation and the plumbing of the
financial system uh once a
convertibility is is broadened so
um you know lastly I would mention uh
you know the pboc also has a number of
swap lines with foreign central banks
and that's a quite extensive network
that could in principle also serve as a
backstop
for any you know liquidity squeezes or
so
um so you know I think it is uh it is uh
in development but uh you know to the
extent that institutions are well
regulated and are well governed
um you know Financial stability risks
should be should be contained we come to
the end of our briefing unfortunately if
you have any questions please feel free
to send it to our mediadimath.org or to
me
um I would like to thank our speakers
Tobias Fabio and Charles also thanks to
you and to our viewers who joined us
today we would like to remind you of the
release of the fiscal monitor tomorrow
morning at 8am in the same room and we
have the original briefings to answer
your questions thank you very much
[Music]
thank you